التصنيفات ليست من عندنا ولكن
بحسب موقع وهو الموقع المختص
وسبع كورفيت بالاضافة الى ثمان
غواصات. جيوش كهذه وقوة كالتي
وغيرها واربعة الاف وستمائة
واربعة وستين دبابة. اما على
غربية? وماذا عن الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي? العلم ان كل هذه
بتصنيفات الجيوش العالمية من حيث
القوة البشرية والبرية والجوية
يمتلكها العرب برأيكم هل تستطيع
اي من هذه الدول التغلب على دولة
واربعمائة وثلاثة وثمانين مدفعا
مطورا. ومائتين وثمانية وتسعين
واربعين قطعة بحرية من بينها
حاملة مروحيات وثلاثة عشر فرقاطة
مستوى القوة البحرية فيمتلك
الجيش المصري مائتين وخمسة
وثمانين الف احتياط وثلاثمائة
الف قوات شبه عسكرية. مع امتلاك
عالميا لعام الفين وثلاثة
وعشرين. والمركز الثاني في
فرقاطات واربع كورفات. لنأتي الى
المرتبة الاولى عربيا. والتي
راجمة صواريخ. بالاضافة الى مائة
وواحد قطعة بحرية. وبذلك استرد
الف وتسع وستين طائرة عسكرية ما
بين مقاتلة ومروحية وتدريب
منطقة الشرق الاوسط وليس عربيا
فقط. بالاضافة الى انها كانت
الاوسط خلف الجيش التركي الذي
احتل القمة. لكن الفراعنة لا
عربيا والثاني والعشرين عالميا
وبميزان ستة واربعين مليار دولار
الثانية عشر على مستوى العالم
لتتراجع الى المركز الرابع عشر
يحتلها الجيش المصري. كانت مصر
قد تصدرت ترتيب اقوى الجيوش في
وتدريب وغيرها. فضلا عن الف
ومائتين وثلاثة وسبعين دبابة.
وخمسة وعشرين الفا كقوات شبه
عسكرية. ويضم الجيش السعودي
ميزانية الدفاع الضخم. حافظت
السعودية على مركزها الثاني
في المرتبة الثانية عربيا ياتي
الجيش السعودي. وعلى الرغم من
الجيش مائتان وخمسة وعشرون الف
جندي فاعل. بالاضافة الى مائة
واثنين وعشرين. فهل تطمح الجزائر
لخطف المركز الاول يا ترى? هنا
بينما الجيش السعودي ايضا سبعا
وخمسين قطعة بحرية من بينها سبع
ما يجعلها بالمرتبة الثامنة من
حيث الانفاق الدفاعي. افراد
وتسعين مركبة ومائتين واربعة
وعشرين مدفعا ذاتي الحركة
ثمانمائة وسبعين طائرة عسكرية.
ما بين مقاتلة ومروحية ونقل
حربية. والف وسبعمائة دبابة
وخمسة وثلاثين الفا وتسعمائة
العتاد العسكري للجيش الجزائري
خمسمائة وسبعة واربعين طائرة
افريقيا. والذي كان قد حل ثانيا
بعد الجيش المصري في الفين
وستون الف جندي بينهم قوات عاملة
واحتياطية وشبه عسكرية. ويضم
الجيش الجزائري المرتبة الثانية
على مستوى القارة من جيش جنوب
الثالثة عربيا جاء الجيش
الجزائري. كما صنفت الجزائر
وهي في المركز السادس والعشرين
عالميا. بجيش قوامه اربع وخمسة
كاكبر قوة عسكرية في شمال
افريقيا من حيث القدرات الدفاعية
دفاع تقدر باربعة وستة وثلاثين
في المائة مليار دولار. افراد
الجيش اربعمائة واربعون الف جندي
فاعل بالاضافة الى اربعمائة
يزالون في المرتبة الاولى على
مستوى الجيوش العربية. وبميزانية
منحهم الجنسية الاماراتية مقابل
رواتب عالية. وهي بذلك كشركة
فاغنر الروسية والشركات الامنية
العالمية مع ثاني اضخم ميزانية
اموالا طائلة. حيث جيش العراق
المرتبة الرابعة عربيا. فيما كان
قد وصل تعداد الجيش الى ذروته مع
نهاية الحرب العراقية الايرانية
ليبلغ عدد افراده مليون فرد.
وبعد الغزو الامريكي للعراق عام
عشر مليار دولار. وبالمركز
الرابع وبرغم الحروب الداخلية
الفين وثلاثة اصدر الحاكم المدني
للعراق بول بريمر قرارا بحل
اذا الى نادي اقوى خمسة جيوش
عربية لعام الفين وثلاثة وعشرين.
جيوش العرب وفي المركز السادس
والثلاثين عالميا. ويبلغ تعداد
دفاع عربية ورقم الثالث عشر
عالميا من خمسة وعشرين واثنين
الذين في الخدمة ما وخمسة وسبعين
الف مع مئة وخمسين الفا من جند
الجيش العراقي ليتم اعادة تشكيل
الجيش وتسليحه من جديد. وها هو
توطينها. فضلا عن تنويع مصادر
التسليح. بينما بلغ عدد الافراد
والفقر والجفاف. يأتي الجيش
العراقي قبل الامارات التي تمتلك
ولنبدأ بالمركز الخامس. جيش
الامارات حيث حل خامسا بين اقوى
ومائتين وخمسة وثمانين الف فرد
في الاحتياط ويمتلك ثلاثمائة
وثمانية واربعين طائرة وخمسمائة
وثمانين دبابة. في المرتبة
عالميا بعدد افراد خمسمائة
وثمانية وثلاثين الفا في الخدمة
طبقا لتصنيف موقع كلوبال فاير
باور الامريكي في المركز الخامس
جيش الامارات مائة الف ضابط
وجندي. لكنهم من جنسيات يتم
الاحتياط. ها نحن نقترب من اقوى
الجيوش العالمية يا سادة فلندخل
دولار. بهدف تطوير الصناعات
العسكرية التي تعمل المملكة على
المرتبة الثامنة جاءت قطر وبرغم
ثرواتها الغازية وتطورها في شتى
في قانون المالية الفين وثلاثة
وعشرين ما يقارب سبعة عشر مليار
والخمسين عالميا. حيث بلغت
ميزانية القوات المسلحة الملكية
الاعتداءات الخارجية. فالجيش في
المركز الحادي والستين عالميا.
الجيش التونسي والذي حل بالمركز
الثالث والسبعين عالميا. وفي
المركز الثاني والستين عالميا.
ليأتي الجيش السوري في المرتبة
السابعة عربيا برغم كل الحروب
التي تخوضها سوريا داخليا وضد
اما جيش المملكة المغربية فجاء
في المركز السادس عربيا والخامس
المجالات الا ان صغر مساحتها
جعلها بعيدة عن اوائل التصنيف في
المركز الرابع والسبعين عالميا.
يسبقه مباشرة في المرتبة التاسعة
والجنوب وصنعاء وعدن الا انه يعد
عاشر اقوى جيش عربي. بل وفي
بمرتبة عربية وفي السادس
والسبعين عالميا. ليأتي قبلهما
وفي المركز الثامن والسبعين
عالميا. يسبقه الجيش العماني
وبالنسبة للجيش الكويتي فقد جاء
في المرتبة الثالثة عشر عربيا
فلندخل نادي العشرة الاقوى عربيا
يا سادة. وهنا في المرتبة
حيث احتل المرتبة الاخيرة في
قائمة دول الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا وفي المركز المائة واحد
عشر عالميا. لكن مهلا فهناك جيش
الجيش السوداني الذي جاء في
المركز الخامس والسبعين عالميا.
موريتانيا الذي ياتي في مرتبة
اقل من لبنان عربيا. بينما يحتل
العاشرة ياتي الجيش اليمني وبرغم
تفككه وانقسامه بين الشمال
العرب. ويبقى لبنان الحلقة
الاضعف. اذ جاء في ذيل القائمة
المرتبة المائة واثنين وثلاثين
عالميا وكأنه خارج التصنيف.
عاملا فردي لتحديد درجة قوة
لدولة معينة مع فئات تتراوح من
والجغرافيا. كل ذلك يعتمدها
تصنيف جلوبال فاير باور. وها هو
التقليدية هي من ضمن العوامل
لتصنيف قوة الجيوش. وهناك خمسون
والواحدة والثمانين عالميا مع
مراتب خارج العشرة الاقوى بين
وعشرين. ليحتل جيش ليبيا والاردن
على توالي المرتبة الثمانين
العالم فاتحة كيف هو حالها
اليوم. وللتوضيح اكثر اليكم اقوى
يعلن تصنيفا لاقوى الجيوش
العربية للعام الفين وثلاثة
الجيوش العربية لعام الفين
وثلاثة وعشرين. قدرة الدول
ومتأخر. والسر يكمن في الجيش.
وبعد ان كانت الجيوش العربية
عدد الوحدات العسكرية والمكانة
المالية قدرات اللوجستية
المحتملة على شن الحرب عبر البر
والبحر والجو وحتى بالوسائل
ومعارك الداخل تدور معارك هذه
الجيوش. والعرب ما بين متقدم
اما بتطلع الازاعة البريطانية
وبتقول ان جمال عبدالناصر كلب
والعلن. من تفاخر بهم الدول
العربية ما بين الحروب الخارجية
الغرب يحسبون لها الف حساب. نعم
فلديهم حماة الشعوب وجنود الخفاء
مسلا زي ما قالوا بنقول لهم
وانتم ولاد ستين كلب.
عندما اجتمعت بعض جيوش العرب
الحقت باسرائيل شر هزيمة. وبدأ
والبحرية.